hey y'all do you love middle ground
i know i do did you know that every
purchase made at the jubilee shop helps
fund this show if you're looking for
ways to support jubilee and watch more
episodes of middle ground make sure you
check out our merch at
shop.jublymedia.com
honestly every one of your purchases
goes such a long way and we're so
grateful for you now enjoy this episode
men are just as sacred as women we are
not more sacred and so we should all
either cover up or go bare-chested
i'm alexa i'm pro-free the nipple and i
think that covering up the nipple is
rooted in a lot of outdated concepts
i want to ask the opposing side beyond a
biological perspective what is the major
difference between a man and a woman's
nipple that makes it so drastic i'm
august i'm pro-free the nipple because i
want to have the freedom to go
bare-chested just like men can
i'm anti-free the nipple movement
because i think it adds the
objectification of women i'm against
this movement because i think that the
answer to our problem of sexualization
is more than just allowing women to be
topless
step forward if you agree
nobody should be allowed to be shirtless
in public
i don't like telling people what to do
but i don't think it's necessary for
anyone to be shirtless in public i think
there's a time and place for when you
take off your clothes in public just out
of respect for other people like i don't
want to see a guy shirtless yeah no i
agree i remember like i would sometimes
walk to school growing up and like all
the track people would be running and
the guys would always be running with
the shirt off and i would get so annoyed
like i just you know i don't really see
a point in someone just walking around
without their shirt or going a new store
without their shirt a guy or a girl
can the disagree or step forward
i mean like i don't think there's a need
to go topless at any point i think it's
just more about like convenience
especially if it's like really hot out
like i don't really want to be wearing
shirts especially like in new york where
i live it's really like humid and stuff
i don't know i just
shirts are kind of uncomfortable in that
context like a man walking around
shirtless in a grocery store is going to
be weird regardless and i think a woman
doing that was would be weird as well um
but if a man goes with a shirt off on a
beach um and a woman were to do that i
think that should both be
fine the context does matter but as a
whole even if we do change society to be
more free in that aspect the core of
these issues isn't going to change
because like in other countries when
they you know they have a different
mindset than we do and the issues are
still prevalent like the core of like
how crappy humans are or can be
doesn't really change whether or not you
allow people to be free or not
it will
i absolutely believe that it will
and and i think it's a very simple
matter of
obliterating misogynists and that's not
just men but women who uphold misogyny
which comes from conservative thinking
why do you think that is
like what makes you think that having
that freedom is the answer
abrahamic religions
have so much influence over the way
we all have grown up and our parents and
their parents
and i'm
i'm going through my own cleansing
process of of things in my upbringing
that came from
my parents
raising them
that trickled down into my raising my
kids that is harmful absolutely harmful
and disgusting and pathetic
breasts are inherently sexual
if the whole entire body is inherently
sexual a shoulder
the tip of a nose even eyelashes
everything can be
become erogenous
i totally agree with you of everything
you said
but i think inherently they're not
sexual i
do doula work and so i care deeply about
women's bodies and
the nature of child-rearing and child
childbirth like when we're born
hopefully people don't sexualize babies
and actually when i work with parents i
make sure that they don't objectify
their child i'm like this is your child
this is they're not your mini-me they're
not yours to play with they're not your
doll they're not your toy
they're their own person and we should
treat them with respect i just don't
think that inherently bodies are
supposed to be sexualized at society and
people who have sexualized the body like
i was in dance for a long time and i was
like also in sports so i just can't
imagine like not being able to wear
sports bra when playing soccer like i
just feel like that'll just cause a lot
of discomfort when it comes to like
running and stuff i feel like it would
be harder to do those things without a
sports bra like you're gonna be bouncing
everywhere
i think that the answer isn't freeing
the nipple and just letting everyone be
liberated i think the answer is that in
your home teach your child how to
respect someone's body how to respect
themselves and
my mom might get mad at me for saying
this but like in my home she was almost
never dressed she's super super
christian but at the same time that
should be in my home i guess more as
appearance wise if we're talking free
the nipple i don't see the difference i
mean i'll be candid i've seen both male
and female nipples before in my life
and i couldn't really tell a difference
i will say on that though i'm a
transgender woman so when i started
transitioning my nipples changed a lot
they became a lot more puffy they become
bigger bigger areolas um and they became
a lot more sensitive i think part of the
sexualization of female nipples is
because
of that it's like an erogenous zone as
well that's like one aspect of it right
so i will say like they're a bit
different i think that women's bodies
are really sacred and i don't feel like
i need to take off my shirt to feel like
equal to a man if that makes sense a
biological male but i think it goes
beyond even
being equal to a man because we're now
more than just met men and women i have
a child who is recently identifying as
non-binary
and
just yesterday i met a biological woman
who was
she's had her breasts removed i am
augmented and lopsided i want all of us
including you
to be able to just be free men are just
as sacred as women we are not more
sacred and so we should all either cover
up or go bare-chested
this movement will lead to more sexual
attacks against women
i hesitate a lot because i think part of
this movement for me is
to change that culture and to change the
desexualization of the bodies and i
think with that increased
desexualization less like less attacks
will happen um
in new york where i am it's legally
topless since 1992. so i take advantage
of that quite often but because of the
sexualization of my nipples um i've been
like harassed been masturbated at been
like assaulted in other contexts i'm not
going to be ignorant and say like that's
not because of my nipples but i'm also
not going to victim blame and say like i
deserve that because i'm showing my
breasts
i agree i i think in in some way it
might be a matter of getting worse
before it gets better
but we can't know that until we
implement it more places i have also
been
masturbated at
by
a neighbor
i he did it twice
i would go out in my yard
dressed from head to toe in what i call
grubbies to do yard work i was not
looking cute and yet my neighbor he took
a liking to it a little too much of a
liking and so i lived in fear for a
really long time
i was yelled at for breastfeeding also
many many years ago and it shocked me
and it made my infant cry yeah and the
man who who got caught looking um
decided that he was mad that he got
caught
and
said that i was disgusting and i was
foul for showing my breasts in public
i disagreed because if a regular person
is walking by and some a woman's topless
i don't think that someone who is not
intending to do that i don't think
they're going to just change their mind
and go and attack someone but i just
thought about all the women who have
been assaulted who've been like fully
clothed i definitely noticed that when i
am topless in new york it's like people
pay attention to me more so i guess like
me having my nipples showing like is not
going to lead to me being assaulted but
it will lead to like
more people paying attention to me and
attracting all people including those
bad people
we can't really say that anything more
is going to happen because i think no
matter
what rules are in place people are still
going to
be really horrible but i do think it's
going to take away the sacredness of the
body i'm curious as to what your
response to me would be when i say like
people paying attention to me more
because i'm topless and i'm perceived as
a woman
being topless
does draw attention
and takes away from someone really
getting to
focus on who you are as a person and
what you're able to offer besides your
body and that's not to say that like in
my past like i definitely wore
suggestive clothing or i would be
intentional about how i dress because i
wanted certain attention did you guys
see the billy eilish commercial when she
was it was like a calvin klein
commercial and she was like fully
covered i think she's wearing like a
tracksuit and she talked about like
objectifying and how she found it more
empowering not to do like the
stereotypical calvin klein commercial
like the free the nipple and going
topless is empowering but i think also
it can be empowering not to do that and
to wear
i don't know like a t-shirt or a
tracksuit i think to me the free the
nipple movement comes down to choice
rather than like inherently showing that
like this is liberating because it is
really liberating for some people and
it's really not liberating for other
people i like to look at things from a
historical perspective um because like
this has been done before i think circa
1937 before then
men couldn't even show their nipples in
public they would protest on the beaches
and they got arrested a bunch of times
it took a very long time until
some judge was like yeah that's fine and
then
here we are today it hasn't even been
quite a hundred years since then so
i was born in 1976. so in my 45 years on
this planet all i know
is
that i have not been able to be
bare-chested and have even been yelled
out for breastfeeding but men always
have been able to
children should not be exposed to
nipples
someone who maybe grew up in a very in a
household where
no one walked around shirtless
and then someone
walks around shirtless in public i feel
like that might
create a really big shock factor for the
kid or it might make the kid feel
uncomfortable
i guess that's my like apprehension
you say about like shock factor and
stuff i think to focus on that and to
like
prevent children from seeing nipples is
to say like to educate the children that
like oh this is something bad this is
something i should not look at um and
that only just perpetuates the
sexualization again like of nipples um
that i believe is
not necessarily helpful if a kid were to
see like a nipple in public it's like
not the end of the world and it's like
actually helpful to like encourage that
and to me like seeing a male nipple
versus like a female nipple in public
shouldn't make a difference if that like
how a child sees that i remember the
first time i saw
like a breast
was in a book about um like african
tribes and there were like women that
were feeding their babies and i was just
like what is this and people did not
explain
to me
what what that was and if i did see a
nipple or i did see a naked body what is
unfortunate is that some people do push
that down and just like oh we don't talk
about that just uh i guess i guess i
want to ask you guys a question
regarding
children i guess if we could find like
some way to incorporate this free the
nipple movement into sex education
especially at the elementary level about
consent and like what the body is what's
when's okay to sexualize when it's
probably not okay um would you how would
you feel about that i guess i think sex
education should be in the home and i
understand that some people don't have
great parents so from my private school
experience they did not talk about sex
education in a healthy way and so i
think there is a problem there does need
to be
developmentally appropriate conversation
but i i really believe that that should
be up to the parent
women's bodies are entitled to the same
rights as men's bodies
yeah so i think the notion of like a
female body person male body as a
transgender woman is very interesting
you know for 18 years of my life
basically i could take off my shirt and
like be totally fine with that in the
world and i started hormones when i was
in the closet so i was like passing as
male and i had breasts right but i could
still take my shirt off and it's only
once i started like being gendered as
female that that wasn't the case and to
me that's very like
ambiguous of like where i started
passing as female because passing and
people perceiving me as female such like
an individual experience
so i disagreed only because um i don't
like the wording of entitled we're a
very spoiled country
yes
we should all have equal opportunity but
like
you know no one's entitled to show
anything or do anything that they don't
want to do and so i just didn't like
that phrasing let's say that we're
getting closer to a point where seeing
all people able to just
walk around bare chested if if that's
going to be so weird that we go in the
opposite direction and it's like okay
guys you can't go shirtless anymore
imagine
the shock they're gonna be like no way
you can't do that to me i've heard a lot
in this conversation about stuff being
fair and and
um and the entitlement just really
bothered me life isn't fair society
isn't fair people aren't fair but as a
whole i just don't think that the
movement is the answer to the issue we
have
with this whole
the society crap
[Music]
you